l'association utopique bazar propose des
ateliers stage pédagogique en arts du
cirque pendant les vacances scolaires
hamas car un jardin botanique de la
réunion une initiation à léquilibre la
jonglerie ou encore l'acrobatie
mais c'est une découverte à tâtons il va
très doucement on leur propose des
objets on leur donne des temps de
découverte où ils vivent librement ils
peuvent aller toucher ils peuvent aller
centre ils peuvent aller explorer les
objets différents que ce soit des objets
de jonglerie comme nous pouvons voir mes
enfants qui sont derrière moi qu'ils
sont en train de faire du jonglage en
extérieur ou des fonds mais aussi dans
une salle en fait sur des tapis on peut
explorer les tapis au sol avec notre
corps peut explorer aussi des objets en
équilibre comme infinie une boule plein
de petites acrobatique donc il livre
aussi utopique bazar a pour but de
dynamiser promouvoir les pratiques
artistiques culturelles et sportives
mais surtout de veiller à
l'épanouissement personnel de chacun en
rendant accessibles ses activités au
plus grand nombre
notre but en tout cas ce qui ressort de
la fière fière de ski de fear2 fier
d'eux fiers de ce qu'ils ont réussi à
accomplir parce que bien souvent ils
arrivent avec l'impression qu'ils
n'arriveront à rien que c'est très
difficile et il repart de la fière
d'avoir réussi à faire beaucoup de
choses finalement surpris surpris de
leur capacité un stage qui a fait
l'unanimité des enfants conquis de
découvrir le cirque et de se dénicher
des talents cachés
je trouve que c'est un prénom cercle moi
qui n'ai pas du tout fort cancer je le
trouve que j'ai beaucoup progressé
ils sont vraiment très sympa et puis il
ya beaucoup d'objets pour
pour apprendre je trouve que j'adore
j'adore ça et que les ils sont très
gentils
toc toc et sardines dans la propre l'un
d'eux faux nez refait de nouvelles amies
j'aime le bâton du diable vous assiettes
chinoises et le filet des jets j'aime
bien parce que si souvent des trucs que
j'ai mes bien chers
une certitude quand je fais des trucs et
ben je trouve que c'est rigolo et
j'apprends alors simple puisque je
préfère quand même le jeu que j'aime que
jeu que j'aime pas mais j'aime bien le
cirque et j'adore le ténor joseph et les
acrobaties
je mélange de hip hop et déchire que
c'est un style jeu
tous les ateliers magie que c'est
vraiment qui est à bout merci ça à nous
deux ça nous aidera peut-être dans la
vie de stages seront organisés avant la
rentrée scolaire par utopique basara
mascarin jardin botanique de la réunion
du 18 au 22 janvier pour les 3 à 5 ans
et du 25 au 27 janvier pour les 10 à 16
ans